santé à présent réunir trente mille
témoignages d'étudiants autour d'un
questionnaire sur la santé c'est
l'objectif du projet ishare une étude de
l'ansés par les chercheurs de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines en partenariat avec la
faculté de bordeaux par le biais d'un
questionnaire sur internet
les étudiants répondent à des questions
sur de nombreux thèmes comme la
sexualité le sommeil ou encore leur
alimentation
le résultat de cette étude permettra
ensuite elle la mise en place d'un
programme d'amélioration de santé des
étudiants écoutez les précisions
recueillies par william l le but étant
de réunir trente mille étudiants
français qui répond à ce questionnaire
pour ensuite créer des statistiques les
envoya à l'état et enfin mettre des
choses en place pour améliorer la santé
des étudiants l'accès aux soins les
remboursements le questionnaire est
confidentielle c'est à dire qu'on va
demander le nom mais après il va être
anonymisées et ensuite idéalement
demande aux étudiants y répondre dix ans
d'affilée donc un questionnaire par an
pour pouvoir voir l'évolution de la
personne au fur et à mesure en fonction
de l'âge et de la section dans laquelle
il nous on est principalement sur lui
fait est ce qu il ya aussi des actions
qui s'étend sur les bâtiments qui à
versailles il ya beaucoup à sidaction
sur bordeaux et éventuellement sur des
actions à paris quand ça les forums de
l'étudiant par exemple on peut être
présent et effectivement voilà ça va
durer le tampon
qu'on récolte les trente mille étudiants
offre à des actions comme ça